[Music]
two more sun care products are being
pulled from the shelves after johnson
and johnson warned that
benzene a chemical that may cause cancer
was found in some of its sunscreen
products
cvs health says it's halting the sale of
two store branded aloe vera items
out of an abundance of caution on
wednesday johnson johnson announced it's
voluntarily recalling
five new tredina and aveeno sunscreens j
j also said the move was out of an
abundance of caution
in may the lab valley shore reported
that it had found benzene in samples of
78 sun care products it tested including
some cvs health and j j
products we're joined now by dr
elizabeth hale a dermatologist
good morning doctor explain good morning
explain to us what is benzene exactly
and why is it so harmful
so benzene is a known chemical
contaminant it's actually used in the
manufacturing process of petroleum
you can find it in plastics and other
products it's something that's
ubiquitous in the environment and we're
exposed to it every day
by all mechanisms through our skin by
breathing it in by just walking around
cigarette smoke etc it is not a
sunscreen ingredient it's
it's important people understand it's a
contaminant and it's something that
somehow made its way in very small
amounts into certain sunscreens as part
of the manufacturing process
but we know benzene can be linked with
certain cancers
like leukemia and lymphoma it can
decrease blood counts
so it's definitely a problem but it is
not a sunscreen ingredient
so how concerned should people be we've
all been using sunscreen this summer
lots of people use it every single day
should there be a concern
and is there an amount that people you
know should be worried about if they've
used
so these are very minut amounts that
were detected in certain sunscreen
ingredients
and i think it was the responsible and
important thing to do to recall these
products
i got so many calls yesterday in the
office with people asking me just these
same questions
but i reassure them all the products
that we were recalled are
aerosols so for right now i'm telling
people maybe stick with a lotion
but i really want to convey how
important it is that people do use
sunscreen
you're not telling people here stop
using sunscreen apps in any way right
sunscreen is so important as part of a
sun protection strategy because skin
cancer
as you know is the most common cancer in
the united states and it's also the most
preventable
so skin cancer is linked with
unprotected sun exposure
even more than lung cancer is with
smoking so we really don't want people
to be so afraid that they stop
protecting themselves
they really still want to use sunscreen
just be aware of these products that
were recalled
and for the time being i wouldn't use
those products because i'm thinking liz
if it's my newt why tell us about it
because it makes me think they're
concerned about something right that's a
great question i think because
for a hundred years we've known benzene
as a problem not in sunscreens but
overall in the environment and it is a
known carcinogen so
i think what the companies all have to
do not just johnson and johnson but they
all need to do testing to see that their
products and confirm that they're free
of benzene
and hopefully you know we'll nip this
problem in the bud going forward we
mentioned there were 78
products it was found in but only only a
few have been recalled so far do you
expect this to go wider
there probably will be a few more
recalls if i had to guess just because
now everybody is really
scrutinizing and studying as they should
be um and checking within manufacturing
because again this is a manufacturing
issue not a sunscreen issue
so but right now all the products that
have been recalled sunscreen-wise are
aerosols and
everybody needs sunscreen especially
even people yes
yes people of color think they don't
need sunscreen right so skin cancer is
the most common and we're seeing a rise
all across the world and in all skin
types so everybody should protect their
skin all right dr elizabeth hale thank
you